sa vue voilà la deuxième vidéo de la
série philosophie et c'est aussi la
deuxième vidéo qui tente d'exploiter
l'expérience du confinement à celles et
ceux qui n'auraient pas vu la première
je vous encourage vraiment à regarder
avant de lancer celle ci on y introduit
plusieurs petites idées importantes pour
comprendre ce qui va suivre
pour rappel ces vidéos prétendent
simplement proposer un outil de
réflexion
une manière d'approcher et de concevoir
certains pans de l'existence ainsi cela
requiert ce que l'on pourrait appeler de
la charité un manotick par là j'entends
une disposition qui consiste à donner
toute sa chance à la proposition et à
éviter de tomber dans le piège du
straumann ou homme de paille c'est ainsi
que l'on nomme l'attitude qui consiste à
caricaturer une position pour mieux la
décrédibiliser bref on s'était posé à la
fin de la vidéo précédente
cette question importante dans quelle
mesure notre expérience et est déterminé
par les idées qu'on peut en dégager à
quel point nos sentiments sont il
définit par les informations auxquelles
on les associe spontanément pour
continuer notre enquête pose en nous une
autre question que le confinement
soulève la vie vaudrait-elle le coup
d'être vécue si c'était tout le temps
comme ça si on répond oui tant mieux
pont si on répond non il faut tout de
suite demandé pourquoi la réponse peut
être simple bien sûr je suis enfermée
avec un mari kimba on est cinq dans
dix-huit mètres carrés etc
mais la réponse peut aussi être complexe
il me manque des stimulations dont j'ai
visiblement besoin
lesquels prenons un point de départ
bndes amiens on aime être heureux et on
n'aime pas être malheureux
à partir de là il y a grosso modo d'un
côté les choses que j'aime parce qu'elle
me procure du plaisir et de l'autre les
choses que je n'aime pas parce qu'elles
procurent du déplaisir donc un truc tout
bête que le confinement nous révèle
c'est qu'on est bien mieux lotis si l'on
désire sont simples pour le dire
autrement si le but est de maximiser le
plaisir autant se débrouiller pour y met
un maximum de choses et un maximum de
choses faciles à obtenir
ça nous permet donc de faire un tri et
de distinguer les choses qu'on aime en
fonction de leur accessibilité plus on
aime de choses faciles d'accès
plus il est simple de produire du
plaisir ce qui me motive
on l'a vu dans la vidéo précédente c'est
l'objet de maquettes et donc logiquement
l'objet de maquettes détermine la
difficulté de la quête plus ce que je
désire est difficile à obtenir
plus il ya de chances que je sois
frustré donc il y à un premier niveau de
danger ce que je désire et difficile
d'accès la quête risque d'être
dangereuse par là j'imagine une quête si
compliquée qu'elle génère presque
automatiquement de la frustration
par exemple j'ai un désir très
spécifiques être en couple avec telle
personne qui n'est pas libre où je veux
m'offrir tel objet qui est unique et que
le propriétaire ne veut pas vendre ou
alors même quelque chose d'extrêmement
simple mais rares
je vis dans le désert et je n'aime que
la pluie c'est simple mais la quête est
frustrante car la plupart du temps je ne
suis pas satisfait il y à un second
niveau de danger c'est quand la question
de l'accessibilité est couplée à celle
de la complexité
là on dira que l'objet de la quête
lui-même est dangereux parce qu'il est
complexe qu'est ce que j'entends par là
par complexité je veux exprimer le fait
que l'affect se double de sa propre idée
non seulement je suis content
d'expérimenter x ou y mais je suis
content à l'idée que j'expérimente x ou
y
c'est une forme de mise en abyme de
l'expérience elle même à coups de
représentation par exemple une bouteille
de vin rare et cher cela peut être un
objet de quête dont la difficulté tient
principalement à l'accessibilité c'est
le cas si je veux obtenir cette
bouteille avant tout pour la richesse de
l'expérience olfactives et gustatives
qu'elle permet là le seul problème c'est
que je n'ai pas les moyens en revanche
si je veux obtenir cette bouteille parce
que je suis motivée par le désir de
boire un vin que peu de gens sur terre
ont la chance de boire parce que je tire
un plaisir particulier de me savoir
privilégier alors mon désir est hissé à
une représentation et dans ce cas au
delà de la seule difficulté qu'il y
aurait à pouvoir mettre la main sur une
bouteille de romanée conti
je fais face à un autre problème je me
suis engagé à donner un sens
supplémentaire à mon expérience à
travers des symboles autre exemple
rapide on peut aimer avoir un mac ou un
iphone
parce qu'on apprécie l'expérience
d'utilisation d'apple ou parce qu'on se
sert de logiciels qui n'existent que sur
cette plateforme cela fait écho à la
valeur d'usagé de l'objet mais on peut
aussi aimer avoir un mac parce que c'est
cool d'avoir un mac
dans ce cas c'est plutôt la valeur
symbolique de l'objet qui est mise en
avant
cela résonne avec les deux premiers
livres de jean baudrillard le système
des objets et la société de consommation
je ne suis pas un spécialiste du tout
mais je retiens ce si la publicité est
l'acte d'achat ont débordé depuis un
moment la seule question de l'objet et
de ses propriétés
on nous vend et on achète moins un outil
définie par ses fonctions qu'un symbole
un signe un code social qui nous permet
de nous situer au sein de la société
il écrit page 79
on ne consomme jamais l'objet en soit
dans sa valeur d' usage on manipule
toujours les objets au sens le plus
large comme signes qui vous distingue
soit en vous appuyant à votre groupe
pris comme référence idéal soit on vous
démarquant de votre groupe par référence
à un groupe de statut supérieur
plus loin page 86
l'astuce de la publicité est précisément
de touché chacun en fonction des autres
dans ses velléités de prestige social
réifier jamais elle ne s'adresse à
l'homme seul elle le vice dans sa
dimension différentiel c'est à dire que
la valeur symbolique de l'objet joue une
fonction de mise en relation comparative
des individus acheter un mac c'est aussi
acheter son appartenance au groupe des
propriétaires de mac un groupe social
qui n'est pas strictement définies bien
sûr mais qui renvoie tout de même un
ensemble de valeurs symboliques et qui
se définit aussi par différenciation
ce n'est pas le groupe des pc si je pars
du principe que ce que je possède me
représente parce que moins ça exprime
mes goûts mes préférences ça révèle mes
activités et mes centres d'intérêt
alors ma relation à moi est déterminé
par les signes et symboles associés à ce
que je possède
et vous l'avez compris ce que je cherche
à dire ici c'est que le problème ne se
limite pas du tout à la question de la
publicité ou la consommation mais que ça
contamine tous les pans de l'existence
notre goût pour le cinéma ou la musique
nos préférence pour tel ou tel bar ou au
restaurant notre relation à autrui tout
cela aussi est engagé dans un système de
production de signes de symboles et ceux
ci sont les moyens que nous privilégions
pour nous faire une image mentale de ce
que nous sommes
pour définir notre identité personnelle
ce que j'appelle ici un affect complexe
c'est un affect qui chargent
l'expérience d'une image de sa propre
personne
ça concerne donc toute recherche de
reconnaissance ou de statut social toute
quête de valeur symbolique mais pas
seulement
je fais l'hypothèse que nous avons une
tendance spontanée à aller chercher dans
l'expérience des informations qui nous
permettraient de préciser l'image que
l'on se fait de soi même et on risque
donc de préférer les affects qui nous
renvoie une image flatteuse
il ya là un risque dès que notre
satisfaction tient majoritairement à la
représentation mentale que l'on se fait
de sa propre vie il y as danger un car
nous fêtons à l'heure fixée cette
représentation
une fois pour toutes tandis qu'à l'est
en fait fondamentalement instable
vouloir transformer nous résistons donc
douloureusement à son caractère
permanent et 2 car ce désir de fixité
est un péril en tant que tel c'est une
fois de plus celui du mythe de narcisse
nous risquons de nous perdre dans cette
fascination pour soi ce que cherche à
mettre en lumière ici c'est que les
failles à travers lesquels le danger du
narcissisme se glisse dans notre
existence sont omniprésentes et il
s'agit là d'une véritable ali nations
dont nous sommes tous sans exception
victimes mais à des degrés divers
on pourrait résumer par l'hypothèse
suivante plus je cherche à définir mon
identité plus je fais entrer de données
symbolique dans l'expérience que je fais
de la vie plus je suis dépendant de ces
données et plus je vais avoir tendance à
favoriser les données rassurantes
il pourrait même peut-être y avoir là un
fondement psychologique aux biais de
confirmation mais ce n'est que ma petite
interprétation
on peut imaginer un spectre sur lequel
on placerait les choses en fonction de
leur manière de nous affecter
selon qu'elles se rapprochent de la pure
sensation ou du pur symbolique
ces deux extrémités sont bien sûr
théorique elle n'existe pas en tant que
tel mais elles servent à illustrer des
tendances on pourrait dire qu'il y a
d'une part les expériences qui relève
surtout du corps ou de la chair comme le
plaisir qu'il y a à boire un verre d'eau
fraîche quand on a soif et d'autre part
les expériences qui relève plutôt de la
convention ou de l'idée comme le
sentiment de honte par exemple qui tient
avant tout à une représentation mentale
on peut donc interroger la teneur
symbolique des choses qu'on aime un
compliment une bonne note à l'école un
t-shirt finisher quand on termine un
marathon ce sont des plaisirs
principalement symbolique
pourquoi parce que le compliment ne
change rien à ce qu'on est au sens où on
est identique à la seconde qui précédait
le moment où le compliment est exprimée
en l'occurrence mon expérience de ma
propre intelligence
c'est à dire le plaisir ou le déplaisir
que j'éprouve relativement à mes
capacités mentales ne varie pas en
fonction des compléments formulée par
autrui
de la même manière la bonne note ne
change rien au plaisir que nous avons eu
à résoudre l'équation ou à écrire la
dissertation
elle n'a de valeur qu en tant que
symbole conventionnel
la note est un outil pour me permettre
de me juger moi même une bonne note me
fait plaisir car elle m'aide à me juger
favorablement mais cela implique que je
me juge via des critères qui sont
étrangers à l'expérience un t-shirt
finisher ne change rien à notre
expérience de la course ni au fait qu'on
a effectivement terminé le marathon
restons sur cet exemple si je cours tout
nu sur une plage déserte
peut-être que je suis proche du purement
sensorielle car ce que j'aime
on va dire que c'est sentir l'odeur de
la mer le sable sous mes pieds
la vitesse simple de ma foulée etc de
l'autre côté
si je cours avec une montre connectés
que je surveille les données objectives
de ma performance et que mon plaisir
dépend surtout du fait que je réalisais
un bon chrono
ce que je ne peux voir soit dit en
passant qu'une fois que j'ai fini de
courir alors ma joie est plutôt du côté
du pur symbolique c'est à dire de l'idée
de la représentation que je me
fait mon activité selon là où on se
place dans le spectre c'est plutôt
l'activité en elle-même qui est source
de joie ou plutôt les informations que
je peux abstraire de l'activité par
exemple parce que je me demande si je
progresse si je suis bon ou si j'ai
assez couru c'est donc deux choses très
différentes que de répondre à la
question est assez couru en écoutant son
corps ou en regardant son chrono je ne
dis pas d'ailleurs qu'il est impossible
de faire les deux ou que l'une est
nécessairement plus intéressante que
l'autre simplement ça envoie à de
relation à soi différentes l'une est
immédiate et subjective l'autre
médiatisé par des données objectives
parenthèse mon frère à qui j'ai fait
voir une première version de la vidéo
m'a fait remarquer que malgré cette
précision
on a tout de même l'impression que je
valorise le côté gauche du spectre et de
fait une vie de ce côté du spectre est
sans doute plus simple qu'une existence
polarisé à droite c'est le sens de
l'épicurisme puisque contrairement à
l'idée qu'on s'en fait spontanément
cette philosophie était en fait un
ascétisme plutôt cannes et de nice mme
donc l'idée étant donc de savoir se
contenter de peu de ne suivre que le
désir naturel et nécessaire donc un
problème social terrible de notre
système économique
c'est qu'ils encouragent la course à des
plaisirs très sophistiquée et que pris
par l'animation que représente cette
course on oublie de s'assurer que les
autres sont en capacité de satisfaire ce
qu'on pourrait appeler les désirs simple
on pourrait aussi convoqué pascal dont
la remarque sur la misère humaine a
beaucoup circulé pendant ce confinement
être capable de ne rien faire et de ne
ressentir aucun manque c'est être libre
plus on a besoin de stimulation moins on
est libre et ça veut donc dire que nous
ne sommes pas libres de nous mêmes on
est aliéné à nos propres besoins
on pourrait aussi faire l'hypothèse
suivante - on est libre vis-à-vis de
soi-même
plus on est engagé à la résolution de
nos propres préoccupations
moins il ya de place dans nos vies pour
autrui apprendre à se contenter de peu
c'est aussi potentiellement apprendre à
développer notre capacité à nous
préoccuper des autres
je reviens sur le tee shirts finisher
parce que je trouve ça révélateur
le t-shirt finisher est un élément de
distinction c'est quelque chose qui me
démarque de ce qu'ils ne finissent pas
le marathon en ce sens c'est un élément
symbolique qui jouent un rôle dans la
considération que j'ai de ma performance
et donc de ma valeur personnelle en
quelque sorte au moins dans le cas
présent en tant que joker amateurs le
t-shirt en tant que convention est un
avatar d'autrui c'est une sorte
d'abstraction d'autrui matérialiser en
tee shirt qui vient valider ma
performance
comme si le concept général d'autrui de
ma société me disait tu as réussi
quelque chose mais autant il apparaît
normal de donner de l'importance au
jugement d'autrui pour s'assurer de
notre valeur personnelle en tant que
coopérateur social puisque seuls autrui
peut dire si je suis un bon voisin un
bon petit ami
ou un bon patron autant la plus value
sociale de mes performances de sportifs
amateurs étant sans doute nulle au sens
où la société ne s'en portent ni mieux
ni moins bien que je termine le marathon
ou non il paraît plus délicat de
comprendre la pertinence qu'il y aurait
à prendre en compte cette information
dans le rapport à soi
cela fait d'ailleurs écho à la vidéo sur
la loi de l'égocentrisme ordinaire on
pourrait dire qu en me donnant un
t-shirt finisher la société en dit
davantage sur elle et sa valorisation de
la performance que sur moi et mes
capacités athlétiques
bref la question devient f tendance à
réduire autrui à la fonction de tee
shirts finisher c'est-à-dire de feedback
de moyen de comparaison afin de
m'attribuer une valeur ou pour le dire
plus simplement est ce que le rire de
mes amis me remplit de joie parce qu'il
est l'expression d'une communion et d'un
amour partagé ou parce qu'ils me
confirme que je suis drôle
il est donc intéressant de se demander à
quel point nos affects sont complexes à
quel point ils sont travaillés par des
représentations et des symboles par
exemple mon expérience de la course me
paraît tel incomplète si je n'ai pas les
informations objectives qui me
permettent de me comparer aux autres ou
dévaluer ma progression
une dernière chose tâchant de ne pas
trop oublié que notre histoire est
intimement mêlée à celle d'autrui si on
cultive cette tendance à se voir comme
le personnage principal le monde risque
de ressembler un vaste jeu de rôle en
ligne où chacun mène sa quête et juge
autrui selon qu'il représente un allié
ou un rival potentiel
il faut donc faire attention à une
attitude plus ou moins consciente qui
consiste à distinguer parmi les autres
ceux dont le regard med a conforté les
croyances que j'ai autour de mon
personnage est notamment le fait que
c'est bien le personnage principal de ce
dont le regard tendrait plutôt à
ébranler la confiance que j'ai dans
l'idée de ma propre personne c'est
d'ailleurs souvent face à ce type de
regard que se manifeste nos mécanismes
de défense il est très effrayant de se
rendre compte qu'on n'est pas ce que
l'on croît être d'autant plus effrayant
qu'une telle remise en cause de sa
propre identité s'accompagne en général
de la crainte selon laquelle le monde
non plus ne serait pas tel que je le
perçois c'est carrément ma propre survie
qui est engagée par ce diagnostic
car si je ne peux pas faire confiance à
mes capacités cognitives c'est à dire à
tout ce qui est sensé me permettre de
comprendre le monde
je me demande comment je vais faire pour
m'en sortir mais justement c'est ce
qu'on disait notre histoire et en mêlées
à celles des autres la coopération
semble plutôt une bonne idée
merci beaucoup et à bientôt